what non-duplicable assets are you
holding on to right now real estate that
you can't have
you know like
waterfront properties are non-duplicated
but you can't build waterfront
properties
it's just a waterfront property okay
real estate in a
freeway or a
you know
section community that
everybody wants to be there because
transformation-based location-based real
estate is to me is non-duplicatable
collectible cars is non-duplicatable i'm
not an nft guy some people are nfts it's
not what i specialize in
it's anything that i can't have that
there's one offs or two offs or five
offs or limited amount of supply for
what's your most valuable alternative
investment like a sports card or
something like that
what would be a sports car today
no for you for me yeah what would yeah
what's the most valuable yeah sports
card or collectible i have right now
yeah i sold two of them
uh it was a record i sold and i'll tell
you what happened when i sold this card
this is exactly a mistake i made so i
bought these two hockey cards for 540.
18 months later i sold those two hockey
cards it was a record-breaking card ever
in the history of hockey i sold a 2-4
2.2 million dollars in 18 months okay
made nice money
one of the cars a guy bought six months
later he sold for three and a half
million dollars one of them
wow
jeez you should put it up yeah you
should actually show this
when i sold it for 1.29 million
six months later sold for three and a
half million dollars of weighing rescue
cards so i missed out on how much money
two point three million dollars so oh my
god look how much i missed out right
because that was a non-duplicatable
asset one of the guys that tried to buy
my card was wayne gretzky he wanted to
buy his own card because there's only
two graded at that level i got a call
from bruce mcnall i don't know if you
know who bruce mcnall is the former
owner
of the la kings and the former owner of
the best honest wagner card in the world
that he bought with wayne gretzky at a
new york auction in 1994 i believe for
451. that's a 15 million car today i own
a high-end mickey mantle card
uh i own some high-end basketball cards
i got some stuff i got probably a six to
an eight million auto card collection
today that's awesome yeah where else are
you investing are you invested in stocks
car index funds i'm in stock did you say
cars yeah not at all that's not my space
other guys are doing that i'm not in
cars
uh uh if i buy a nice car i'm driving it
the only the other day guy asked me if i
like cars like i'm interested in the sh
in the rolls royce that the shah of iran
had i'll buy that
and i'll put it in the museum and never
drive it because i'm going to look at it
because i remember i was seven years old
when i went to the museum and i saw that
rolls royce and i said one day i'm going
to buy rolls royce if i ever buy that
rolls royce from his museum i'm going to
buy that and i'm going to put in my
house because there's a story behind it
i drive an f-150 shelby 770 horsepower
every day and i got a million out of
ferrari in my garage i never drive it
and i'm in the market to sell it right
now so i don't drive it i've driven a
five or ten which ferrari is that sf90
okay yeah it's a nice one and it's not
comfortable for me i'm not comfortable
in it but
you were asking a question about uh um
you said what do you invest stocks yes i
am in stocks he said cars i'm not in
cars majority of the money right now
that i have is going to go on businesses
that i'm going to operate or have
influence over that's what it's going to
go to okay that's where the investments
are going
can you share some numbers in terms of
like net worth or how much you you make
in a year it's not a public number but i
sold one of my insurance companies
uh
shy of you know it's a multi-multi multi
nine figure check that was sold to
and i owned 83 of it and a lot of it was
cash
uh so i have that and have a big chunk
of stock in a company that's
uh
doing very very well and where it's at
so you know that's that part so you know
if you're asking if you're asking net
worth
you want to count paper or you want to
count cash
let's do both if you want to do cash
cashes
probably sitting on shy of 200 million
of cash right now right now where do you
keep it all
it's in my house i put it in my bedroom
every day i come home and i count it no
yeah but but what do i keep it i keep it
at my uh advisors who manage my money
i'm always curious how they handle that
amount of money
because it's beyond any fdic amounts
it's like it's got to be treasuries and
no no no you put it with some of the
main guys on what they're doing so
you're talking the main guys are who
to talk about the big ones whoever they
are that's where your money's going to
be
you got morgan goldman you know you got
a few other ones that you're going to
put your money in if you enjoyed this
video i give a keynote a few weeks ago
in las vegas specifically on the topic
of cracking a code to content creation
if you've not seen it click here to
watch it take care everybody bye
[Music]